[Musique]
mademoiselle ashton je m'appelle dos et
adam je fais partie du cercle littéraire
des amateurs d'épluchures de patates de
guernesey ont fondé par elisabeth
mckenna ce cercle est devenu notre
refuge pendant l'occupation allemande
sigean ont été contraints de cohabiter
décline où je tiens au phare vrai sujet
d'écriture
un véritable écrivain vient nous voir
ah bonjour dos et adams et votre
fondatrice elisabeth macheda j'ai hâte
de la rencontrer
bouna rencontrerait pas cette histoire
va bien au delà de ce qu'il raconte que
ceux du passé
ce n'est pas à moi de le dire ils ne
veulent pas avec le sujet de mon livre
la guerre n'est pas finie
pas vraiment elisabeth on ne pouvait pas
s'empêcher d'écouter son coeur tu dois
suivre son exemple
tu en as le courage j'ai vu des choses
que je n'aurais jamais imaginé jamais
moi aussi j'ai perdu des proches si vous
le permettez j'aimerais vous aider si
les livres le pouvoir de rapprocher les
gens
celui ci devrait faire des miracles
[Musique]
pas encore goûté à tous la tourte aux
épluchures de patates
[Musique]
le cercle littéraire des amateurs
d'épluchures de patates de guernesey
fichtre tout un programme
[Musique]